that the question that's long followed
Dominic Raab around and now after five
months of this I'm confident I behave
professional at all times I'm confident
I pay professionally throughout a
behaved profession at all times a
decision on his fate now imminent after
the report investigating bullying
allegations against the deputy PM was
handed to his boss Rishi sunak who now
has to decide whether his Deputy stays
or goes That's All Things No tunneling
into a fast can you imagine being a
civil servant who's raised the complaint
the Prime Minister used to think about
what it would be like if it was him in
that situation he's the first minister
of the Civil Service he has a
responsibility to his civil servants to
ensure that they're protected from
building harassment and that they are
treated with respect this is not
treating those civil servants with
respect the allegations of bullying
concern Mr Rob's time as a cabinet
minister across three different
department moments taking in eight
separate complaints with a number of
complainants and while his accusers
await a decision others seek to defend
him I must have attended hundreds of
meetings with him with civil servants
and MPS and other officials and and not
once did I ever witness him behaving in
a manner that could be described as
bully you know yes he expects high
standards of people we've heard lots of
people say this during this
investigation and it's absolutely true
he does set a very high bar for
everybody who works for him conflicting
interpretations of his behavior but the
times of reference of this investigation
clear to establish the facts and to be
completed as swiftly as possible with
the Prime Minister as the ultimate judge
and tonight he's still weighing up the
verdict I'm told the prime minister is
taking his time to go through the report
and consider it thoroughly because this
is a really difficult decision for Rishi
sunak Dominic Rob is one of his most
loyal lieutenants and a trusted
political allies so to park company with
him will come at a personal cost but
this is about politics too if Rob goes
then the Prime Minister will face
questions as to why he appointed him in
the first place and what he knew when if
Rob stays the Prime Minister risks a
backlash from the Civil Service and
questions about whether or not his
really is a government of Integrity
Dominic Robb has seen the report and
maintains he behaved professionally but
the opposition calling for the PM to
adjudicate and fast prime minister
really should be able to read the report
make up his mind and get on with it stop
dithering and delaying and summon up
your courage and Sack your Deputy if
he's a bully every time one of these
conservatives gets into trouble they
don't just undermine the reputation of
conservatives they undermine the
reputation of all members of parliament
and we do need people to have faith in
politics next month the country's faith
will be tested at the local elections
not an explicit Judgment of the PM but
of his party and his record this the
third cabinet minister of rishi's sunach
short Premiership to face the sack the
weight continues Beth Rigby Sky News
Westminster